- All right y'all the hours almost up,
but first I've got one more
awesome story to share.
This is what I'm liking.
(Upbeat Music)
So listen, as good as it is for you.
Sometimes exercising is just
exhausting or dangerous.
So even for people who do it every day,
and that's why we all
need a coach like this,
Cincinnati mama, has at her home.
Watch this
- You're strong and grateful.
You're kind.
Mama, I believe in you.
- Thank you.
- You can do it.
- Thank you so much, baby.
(Laughter)
- She's got her arm up.
First of all, what the
world, you are shaming
moms everywhere with this video.
I'm like good Lord with that body.
That's five year old Jonah
keeping her mom, Janiah
Uber motivated.
And it's just adorable is what it is.
We have them on the line right now.
What's up? Y'all
- Hi, Kelly.
- Hello.
- Hello, it is so lovely
to meet both of you.
Janiah you were having an
especially difficult workout, right?
First of all, it looked hard anyway
just I would never wanna do that.
And your body is exceptional.
Let's start with that.
But you were having kind
of a hard day, right?
- Yes. I was. That day I
actually had a headache
and I was really struggling
during my workout
and you know,
Jonah saw that I was
having a difficult time.
So she stopped playing with her toys.
She came over to motivate me.
She was speaking affirmations to me.
You know, the things that
she heard me say to her
and it really got me through it.
Like how could you quit after that?
After hearing that, those words from her.
- Oh my gosh. She's like
the best coach ever.
So Jonah, like, do you
do you like being able
to encourage your mama
while she's working out?
- Yes.
- Yeah. You are good coach.
You had your arms up.
You were preaching.
I liked all of it.
(crowd laughing)
Oh, God.
Oh my God, I wish you were
here so I could hug you.
Oh my God.
Jonah you.
Okay. I here's what you should do Janiah
next time You're just feeling sad.
Just put her on camera.
It'll make you laugh.
She is so funny.
Jonah. You are so confident.
You're so fun.
We love you.
Thank you for being such a
a great uplifting spirit for your mama.
Mama's need that.
Take it from one mama.
- Bye
- Bye, well, I'm liking your post.
How's that sound?
(doorbell)
and that's not all you
two you're so adorable.
Our season long partner,
pilot pen, makers of G2
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show.
Wanna all honor, ultimate overachiever.
Just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheers)
I feel like with that money, Janiah
you should at least get at
camera, cuz this is awesome.
And should we should all
be able to enjoy this?
This is awesome.
Thank you guys so much. Bye.